[Music]
welcome to the data science hangout
everybody i lost my notes but i should
know this feel by now
but welcome back to those who have been
here before
and a
special welcome to those of you joining
for the first time
for anyone who is joining for the first
time just to let you know how it works
um there's a few ways you can ask
a squash here so you can jump in live
maybe raise your hand on zoom
you can put questions into
the zoom chat
and just put a little star there if you
want me to read it out loud
and then you also can ask questions
anonymously with slido
and so tyler will share that link there
in just a second here
but just want to reiterate that
we love to hear from everyone regardless
of what industry you work in
or your level of experience
so feel free to use that slido link too
if you don't feel comfortable asking
live
just a reminder that the session will be
recorded as well so we'll share up to
the data science hangout site and our
studio youtube
but so excited to have you all here with
us today
and thank you so much for joining us
erin
excited to have you as my co-host
erin
is joining us from charles schwab
and aaron i'd love to
have you just introduce yourself and
maybe share a little bit about the work
that you do on your team
uh yeah so i'm aaron pearson um i
currently work for charles schwab i've
been there for
almost two years um prior to that i was
with td ameritrade who have been
purchased by schwab um
so i've been in financial services for
most of my career um
i
mostly was in trading primarily up until
a few years ago i moved to
a data analyst position at td
and then
then moved to over to schwab
so now my my current position at schwab
i'm
a senior manager in trading operations
which is kind of a general term
my job is kind of
to be
the kind of go-to person for my boss who
um oversees multiple departments within
trading operations like
fraud and trading and
i'm kind of
i've kind of been tasked to
be his kind of go-to person just for
random data related things um
different dashboards um ad-hoc queries
um you know looking at different data
sets trying to um
identify patterns and things like that
so i'm still uh
fairly new to the position so i'm still
kind of figuring it out honestly we're
kind of
um
just kind of going day by day and seeing
what comes up so
still in progress
i know you were
a trader before and moving into this
role so i'd love to hear a little bit
about that transition as well
yeah that was actually what got me
interested um i was
um i was a trader for many years um i
was a trader on our block trading desk
so i dealt with um you know large trades
did a lot of used a lot of algorithms to
do block trading
and um through that process i kind of
started looking at the different
algorithms and kind of got interested in
um
how they how they worked um and kind of
thought well it'd be cool if i could
like do one on my own you know so maybe
i should study coding so that's kind of
what started it so um
i started looking into coding started
learning
sql and python and r um and
through
that i kind of
um my my boss at the time on the block
trading desk he was incredibly
supportive and he said yeah you should
run with this so let's take you off
day-to-day stuff you know and give you
some room to to study that stuff so he
allowed me to do that so that's kind of
what got me into it and i just kind of
you know kept going with it
that's amazing was was there a certain
moment where you said oh i should
i should do this or i could look into my
own algorithm
i mean yeah it was just just
through through trading we would um
get exposed to
more and more algorithms because
different um different firms have
different algorithms proprietary
algorithms and so i was just like i
could probably do this i could do my own
maybe you know i don't know i don't know
how hard it is let's give it a try so i
just kind of started taking classes and
um just you know free online classes
just whatever i could get
um and then our uh
uh
a guy over in data analytics
dot td um who was kind of under the same
umbrella as me who i've known for years
um kind of started talking to him a
little bit about what he did and what i
was doing
and
um it just kind of worked out that he
actually had somebody on his team leave
and um my current boss actually reached
out to him and said hey you should hire
aaron that would be a really good fit
and so i kind of started talking to him
and he actually hired me um so that was
kind of how i got my
first job in data um because i don't i
honestly don't know if i would have
otherwise because i didn't i didn't know
anything i was
you know i was still learning i was very
new very green
um but luckily um
he actually saw that again he knew me
for probably 10 years at that point so
he knew me he knew i was hard working he
knew i was smart
um and
because i had all of that trading
business knowledge you know he he saw
that value um but you know you can teach
your teacher to code but she understands
like the underlying um data that she's
looking at and what she should be
looking at and so um luckily he
recognized that and gave me kind of a
shot so
i was really lucky that i had really
supported people
that's great and that kind of brings up
a point i know we talked about
a bit earlier is
how you actually navigate
huge companies
like charles swab or ameritrade um
and i think that's one opportunity of
doing that as well like networking
within the company to get you to
the role that you had
yeah that was huge i like i said i
probably would not have gotten that job
otherwise you know i don't know you know
just freshly
applying for something
that you know where the people don't
know you just looking at my resume i
don't know that you know any hiring
manager would have taken a chance at me
maybe but i don't know
i didn't uh
uh unfortunately i didn't have to find
out
yeah it's um definitely making those
contacts was was exactly how i got
um got that job and even my current job
um
when i was um so i was very happy at td
i was a data analyst in advanced
analytics doing a lot of trading data um
loved it
um but i was um
i spoke with somebody from schwab side
who um again realized that i had some
technical knowledge and i had all that
trading knowledge and that i would be a
really good fit for their team and so a
friend of a friend kind of hooked us up
and talked about a position and that's
kind of how i got my current position um
so now i'm in a
it's it's it's one company you know
because we are emerging or in the
process of it but it's still two very
different companies two different very
different data structures and
um organizational structures so it's
been um i'm still kind of navigating the
schwab side um
because i'm not in a traditional
data position
um you know i'm not on a data team i'm
on a trading operations team
um the data person within that team so
it's kind of like on my own island i
don't have i don't have colleagues
directly that
do what i do so
um
it's been a journey trying to find those
people i'm slowly learning you know you
just you kind of have to find this
person and kind of pick their brain and
let them know what
what you um
what you're doing what you want to do
what you're thinking about and then
maybe they can refer you to somebody
else who has this knowledge and this
person has this knowledge and you just
kind of have to be patient and kind of
um
you know keep all those contacts open
and
be open to talking to people you don't
know and put yourself out there
but it's definitely um yeah i'm still
very much in the middle of it at this
point
i talked to a lot of people who are in
that process as well how do you
find the first people to go reach out to
um
well i
i knew a little the td side i knew a lot
of people
so um i did kind of
uh ask
a few people like have you had have you
talked to your counterparts on the on
the show side yet you know do you have
any names
and that um i did you know just ask my
manager because my my manager knows that
i
you know came over and i'm relatively
new to the show upside so he actually
um
gave me a couple names he gave me a
couple intros that kind of um
started that so just recently within the
last couple weeks i've been introduced
to a couple people um that i think will
really kind of start to get me on the
right path
as a reminder everyone feel free to
raise your hand to ask questions live if
you want or you can use the cyto
as well
um
but erin as you start to like grow that
community within schwab as well how does
everybody
kind of like stay
in touch or
or keep growing that community
uh well we have um
because we're a big company um we do
have some set um
communities within like data communities
within the firm um so there's like
there's a tableau
monthly group that meets um that does
like presentations and contests and
things like that and we also have a data
science group that which which um
focuses more on like python and r and
again people um present things and we
have um chats and teams so you can
always reach out um you know hit
something up in in the teams and ask a
question or
um you know say i'm working on this code
and it's not working right is anybody
you know can i maybe take a look um or
you know how do i download this package
or
install this or you know um we have
those kind of channels that where we can
kind of communicate with each other
which is really helpful
that's awesome
i see there was an anonymous question
that came in a bit earlier that was
what ratio of r to python sql or other
do you use
and
what about most other data scientists
traders that you know
well right now i personally use sql
a lot
um
but i know that
it just kind of depends on what kind of
team you're on and what you like to use
because mostly you can use anything um
for for for most projects
um but primarily um in my my current
position i'm using sql like 90 of the
time because most of it is
um data mining um
trying to find
where the data is that i need and then
trying to put it together so that's
that's my my number one at this point
i'm
and also i uh
i kind of
i kind of took a break from data in a
way when i moved from cd to schwab um
because my position
the first year um well let me back up so
i was hired and then my boss quit
um
uh
she actually went to a different firm
six months into my um tenure at schwab
so that kind of
threw a wrench into my entire
career progression so
um initially when i was hired i kind of
was hired into the team to start
learning what the team does the
day-to-day stuff
i was on the regulatory reporting team
so i was learning
everything that they did
and so that was kind of what i was was
doing initially and so i wasn't really
working with data much like a few
queries here and there but nothing
nothing nothing
data focused
um so then once my once my manager left
i was kind of stuck in that spot for a
year
um so i didn't really do a whole lot of
data and then eventually we kind of
found the right place for me um
so then i got back into data so now i'm
kind of actually i'm going back and kind
of taking classes to refresh myself on
like python and r because it's been a
while since i've actually used them so
i'm hoping to use them more um you know
in the coming months but i'm kind of uh
brushing up on things right now to be
honest
i know that that is the topic that had
come up before on a hangout and someone
else had experienced that where they
joined a company and then like 30 days
later their boss quit yeah
yeah
yeah so i know we didn't get a chance to
get to that question a few weeks back so
i'd love to
maybe hear if other people have
experienced that as well or if people
have any advice
for others to
get into that situation
i don't have any advice all i know can
really be like the ground just shifting
under you
and in retrospect thinking about when
that's happened before
you know i guess i would really ground
myself more to to a higher the sort of
next echelon
of purpose
um
not you know knowledge
so that you're not
you don't feel any kind of codependency
there
which obviously i mean with your boss
it's
clearly a thing
uh it's just to keep ourselves
independent is is definitely
a mission and a constant
struggle
thank you ali
aaron going through this now do you have
advice for us as well
um i think
the only thing that
i did that i'm really grateful that i
did was
um when my when my manager left i was
i was
like what am i gonna do like
i made the biggest mistake of my life
why did i move i was so happy my
previous job like what did i do
um and i was i was pretty freaked out to
be honest
i didn't know what i was gonna do um but
the um
they they slid over my now manager um
over our team and so he i was reporting
to him and i just kind of started
talking to him about like
this is not what i was hired to do i
could do a lot more um
kind of bored
you know um i just kind of started
talking to him about what my skills were
and what um i had
what we had discussed my position being
and
he was like okay let me work on that let
me you know talk to people and and
luckily he um he cared enough to
um figure out the position that i should
be in
um
and so
he was kind of thinking about
hiring somebody to be kind of his data
person
um he was already kind of thinking about
that so then when i approached him about
that he was like oh this could be
perfect you know this will work
um and so yes would you want to do that
and i said yeah of course so
um just
making
making him aware of
exactly where i was and um
what i wanted to do like that was huge
if i wouldn't have done that
i don't know uh i'd probably just be
doing regulatory reporting
i guess
which is fine but it wasn't you know
what i was hired to do so i think that
is the biggest thing you just have to
um
talk to people and let them know
um
what you're capable of doing what you're
interested in doing and hopefully you
have somebody that's in your corner that
will you know kind of help you get to
where you want to be
yeah i think it's a hard conversation to
have too like
this isn't this isn't what i was tired
to do
yeah when i when i talked to him i i
didn't want to sound
ungrateful or like oh i hate my job you
know you don't want to be negative like
that so i tried to approach it and you
know like i'm learning a lot you know
this is great but like
i could do more you know you hired me
technically for this job and i'm not
doing that job and right away he
understood he's like yeah that's not
what we hired you for so we need to get
you to do what we hired you for so
luckily he recognized that
again i've i've been very lucky to have
a lot of really great management over
the years that have really kind of
recognized what i can do
um and and have been really supportive
so
very lucky
yeah and well as nick just said in the
chat too good for you for for speaking
up about that too
i see ali you had asked a question on
slido a bit earlier if you'd want to ask
live
sure i was just wondering about uh side
projects within wall street uh
technologically based that are more
focused on community development and
education
if you knew anyone who's is engaging in
that or if there's a department that
that looks over that
for schwab specifically i know within
the finance wall street community
um i mean i don't know of anything
specific um there are there are
different groups out there um that
that host things here periodically
like different firms will host you know
kind of data meetups and
um
presentations over things but
i'm not
not thinking of anything specific
nothing's coming to mind
thank you i appreciate your you're
hanging out with us
of course thank you
and if other people know about
other events do you feel free to share
them in the chat
i know
there's our there's the r for finance
um
conference and they
i think there was a call for speakers
that might still be open
try and find the link bad at
multitasking
um
i see nessa you
you had a question here on
that last conversation about what to do
when you say this isn't what i was hired
for
would you want to jump in and and ask
that
yeah sure um i mean that's that's the
only thing i'm asking really um
more like yeah what
i'm kind of curious as to whether
you do know any advice for what might
happen if
you know you you have that
conversation about roles about not quite
what i was expecting not quite what i
was initially told but
um
and yeah i guess i guess i'm asking if
it's sort of less accepted possibly
because
you know i guess there could be many
reasons for that right but
possibly if whoever hired that person
was
you know
overselling a little maybe
can't like how to have that conversation
if if you know i'm just kind of curious
if you have any advice for that sort of
situation
i mean
really the best advice is just to be
honest and let let them know how you're
feeling about it um i mean the bottom
line is if you're not having your job
you're not going to stay in your job and
they don't want you to be unhappy
because they don't want to lose you you
know if if you're not happy you're not
going to be doing good work
so i mean
um
kind of like
kind of like what i said earlier like
you have to be a little you have to have
a low finesse about it you can't be
super negative and you know just say i
hate my job and give me a better job um
but you can say
you know i i'm really interested in
doing xyz you know and i i appreciate
this job i'm doing this i'm learning
this that's great um but i i could also
be doing more and i'm interested in
doing more and just
just kind of have to phrase it you know
to where kind of like you know what can
i do for you even though it's really
more for me
that's very fair yeah that's that's
great answer thanks
i see there
let's see other anonymous questions
tyler
oh
there was another question that just
came in that was apart from sql r and
python how important
was the role of statistics
um
it is it's it's
i did so i had i studied
statistics a little bit in college i was
uh my undergrad i was in a psychology
major so i did do some research and some
statistics classes
um so it helped to have like a
foundation um
it's not
i mean i wouldn't say it's a deal
breaker but i think it's definitely
helpful to just help you understand
things when you're looking at them
um
i mean i i feel like it came more into
play when i was
doing like graduate work
um with classes but my day-to-day
um
having just a basic foundation is good
because you're just doing kind of when
you're looking at like averages and you
know just the basic statistics stuff
but i mean
i honestly i haven't really found an
occasion to really dig into like my old
stats books and refresh things um
but again that very much depends on your
job i'm not i'm not heavy in the weeds
of the data world yet um i might get
there um as i as i grow in my position
but right now you know um
that's not something that i'm i've had
to focus on
thank you i i see there's a conversation
happening in the um
chat right now about different
like r and health care groups or r and
pharma r and finance and where people
find those
[Music]
and jill i see you asked the question
anyone know of r for healthcare group
if other people have things that they
know of or events feel free to
put those in chat too
we plan a quite a few different industry
meetups but still trying to figure out
how to like
keep that community going like getting
people talking whether it's through
slack channels or
other formats
so i would always love to talk about
that more and if anybody's ever
interested in speaking at a meet up or
i don't know it wants to wants to just
brainstorm about because getting those
community goings let me know
um
i see sloan you asked a question around
networking do you want to jump in and
ask that one sure
um i was just curious uh if you have any
tips for networking within your own
company whether that's something that
just happens naturally or do you take
like set up meetings with people to try
and get to know them to try and build
relationships that way or any
recommendations for how to go about
doing that
um
i've
it's been pretty natural for me i guess
um
i'm a pretty shy person but i'm also
pretty social so um
i was i was with td for 15 years so i
started there really young you know when
you're young and you know everybody's
going out all the time and you kind of
build those relationships and then they
grow over time so that at td ameritrade
it was pretty easy to just kind of
um
foster those relationships out of a
social kind of environment
at schwab it's a little different
because i i started at schwab
in the middle of the pandemic or right
when it started really in may of 2020 so
i don't know anybody
um i've only met i've met my boss in
person once and that's the only person
i've seen in life
um that i work with so it's a very
it's a very weird um
kind of situation to navigate so
um now my goal is to basically just
kind of reach out um
um
ask people you know do you know anybody
that knows this um do you know anybody
that knows anything about this and then
i'll just hit them up in teams and say
hey so-and-so gave me your name
um i'm hoping maybe you can help me or
you know maybe we can just you know
touch base and um
[Music]
just kind of
try to reach out and
um
you know
on teams is really my only my only
source at this point but it's you know
it's it's working it's i think the thing
is you just have to be patient
because you don't meet everybody in the
first day um you don't ever you don't
meet everybody that you need to meet
initially you know it just it kind of
grows so you just kind of have to be
patient and put yourself out there and
um
participate in things you know i'm
usually
for schwab anyway it has it's a huge
company but they have a lot of little
little things that you can do
like last week we had like a tableau
contest for
um st patrick's day you had to do a st
patrick's day dashboard so like you know
i did one for that just to kind of
participate and you know get your name
out there and and you know you kind of
meet people that way just um by
participating in any kind of like silly
little challenges or
discussions on things um just you know
kind of keep keep open to to what's
available out there and and try to put
yourself out there as much as you're
comfortable
thank you i think uh
trying to navigate building
relationships virtually
i found it it requires a lot of
intention behind it versus what happened
naturally in person because i had a
similar experience i started my job
march 2020 and i've met my boss in
person i think three times now so we've
we've gotten the number up a little bit
but it's nice to hear that i'm not the
only one that is kind of going through
that experience
yeah i think i think honestly i think
there's a lot of people because we've
been in this
excuse me for two years now so there's a
lot of people that have started new jobs
in the last two years so i think we're
all you know kind of trying to navigate
that together
that's great advice so thanks aaron
um
looking to a few other questions i see
ismail
ismail you asked a question um
i think on slido do you wanna ask it
live
uh sure i put it in the chat
but
uh my question offering is like it seems
like you have an eye or insights on
finding good supporting leaders
you seem that you have to the multiple
supporting leaders um
how do you measure that or how do you
find insights or
determine
uh when a leader is like supportive or
encouraging of your and your career more
than just like a boss you know
curious to see your insight on that
you know i i think i just got lucky
um
i mean i was just kind of blessed with
having people in my in my um
org that were great i mean i had people
that weren't too you know don't get me
wrong um like i said i was with td for
15 years so i had several you know
managers over that time but i just i was
really lucky with some good ones and i
mean how you figure out if they're good
is you
you talk to them about what you want to
do and what you um are interested in and
if they if they care enough to help you
or not you know some managers do and
some managers
are just your boss and do your work and
shut up you know um but i i find that
the majority of them
um
do have you know an actual
um
vested interest in making you better um
the good ones anyway so and i do think
that most of them out there um
are you know are are willing to put in
that work because otherwise
why are they doing that job in the first
place um
but yeah you just have to
you just have to put yourself out there
and let them know how you're feeling and
see if they
are uh receptive to it or not
yeah i don't think i did anything
specific to to find those people i think
i was just very lucky that they kind of
were in my orbit and i you know
connected with them
thank you for that um but you're great
advice for putting yourself out there
right so thank you
do you have those conversations
about your like professional development
or career growth with those managers did
you
proactively schedule time with them or
was that just part of
natural like one-on-ones with the
manager
um it kind of depended on the person um
but when you're so i've been in the
corporate environment my whole
professional career and generally when
you're in a corporate environment you do
have scheduled one-on-ones and
performance reviews and things like that
so that's you know that's always
something that's there and that's when
you can talk about that but
um
but also you know just one offs um
you know like hey what's going on this
week what are you doing oh i'm taking
this class you know i'm learning this
and then they're like oh cool what do
you want to do with that you know you
kind of just start kind of fostering the
conversations like that um so it can
work both ways
thank you
i see there are um a few anonymous
questions
i'll go to and one was can you discuss
how you take algorithms and other diver
deliverables from the lab stage into
production for schwab both from a
technical point of view and also how you
foster trust
um
well no i can't actually um i haven't i
haven't um
utilized algorithms for a few years now
um i really did that when i was actually
in trading and
at that point um we just had a surface
level of algorithms they were provided
to us by um
different vendors so we didn't have any
internal
um algorithms so i can't really speak to
that unfortunately um that is something
that hopefully
you know i'll get into as i'm as i'm
here a little bit longer and
and uh develop in my in my current
position but yeah unfortunately i don't
have that knowledge right now i wish i
did
thanks aaron i see mike you have your
hand raised if you want to jump in
yeah
thanks aaron this this has been
a great conversation i wanted to come
back to the the discussion about
managers again i like you i think i've
been really lucky
in having a succession of really
supportive and and great managers and it
it transforms your day-to-day work
because they just are there for you and
want to see you you know do your best
i think it's harder
if you run up against someone who's more
obstructive
you know who who isn't that same kind of
supportive person
and
i i've had it once
and actually it's a difficult place to
be
you know and
to avoid it really rather than it can
bump up against that person and and have
a fight or
or quit i kind of reached out internally
to to find another role that i could do
and hit up my network and say come on
you know i'm fed up where i am what have
you got
um
but it's a really tough conversation to
have with him with
anyone you know manager or not to say
i don't feel this is going how the way
that you think it's going
so any thoughts or advice about you know
having those difficult discussions
i mean yeah i think if you if you have
that manager that's not supportive i
mean you have to look elsewhere you have
to you have to use your network you have
to reach out to your to your colleagues
and maybe different departments or maybe
even different firms and say hey
i need help i need i need i need
something to help me grow because i'm
you know i'm dying here
um so yeah i mean that's that's what you
have to do you just have to
um if sometimes you can't change people
so if
if your current manager is not
supportive
they're probably not going to be
supportive you know next month or a year
from now so how long do you want to
put up with you know being miserable in
your job um right yeah you just gotta
you gotta look up look elsewhere and
find find something else but that's
really hard definitely
it's also doubly difficult because of
the fear of the unknown
you know if you've done that role for a
few years or or longer
then any change is going to be
uncomfortable
or or based on sarah
right when i um when i
leaving um td to come to schwab was
it was completely life-changing because
i had
i'd been with td since i was a kid
you know like that was the only company
that i really ever known since college
and
um
leaving all of my my friends that i made
there um and my my really good work
colleagues and my network you know
i had a really good
a really good network of people that
knew me that would you know sing my
praises if i ever needed anything um you
know that that just knew me and i can't
you know coming to a completely
different company was
very very scary even though you know it
was similar but like
yeah i mean the fear of the unknown is
definitely definitely a real thing
thanks mike and
and
taking that a bit further this question
could be for
for everybody on
someone asked anonymously does anyone
have suggestions for how to gauge
whether a manager will be supportive
a supportive one during your interview
process
and feel free to put thoughts in the
chat or jump in too
well i think that's one thing you have
to ask in an interview like
admittedly i haven't been in that many
interviews because i've been with you
know
the same firm for so long um but
i think that's that's definitely
something that should be on your list is
um
you know how
how do you foster growth like how um
what are the opportunities for growth
within this um within this position um
do you have learning opportunities do
you allow classes do you have internal
classes like that's kind of the stuff
that you just have to ask to see kind of
um how receptive they are to that i
think if you put that out there and if
they don't have an answer
that tells you everything you know but
if they're supportive of that i think
they'll already know exactly what to
tell you so i think you just have to ask
personally
one thing i would suggest is to um
talk to other people that have worked
for the
the manager
you can get a really good sense
even if the person is not totally
straight up with you
make sure you can see their face
so
that's a great point
yeah one thing whenever i've hired for a
team is i generally have hope like the
peers of the person that we're hiring
interview
and
hopefully people are seeing more of that
and if they don't give you the
opportunity to ask for it
yeah that's how that's how my interview
was i at schwab i interviewed with the
entire team i had a call with every
single person on the team and then uh
two people that were that worked um
closely with the team but in different
departments and that was
definitely huge that kind of gives you
an idea of what you're walking into
you want to shift gears too quickly if
someone else wanted to jump in
javier is like i see that you asked a
question in the chat too it's a bit
longer i'm going to have you ask it live
thanks rachel
hi aaron i loved your presentation so
far um
i'm just curious there's a great book
i read a few years back it's called
weapons of math destruction
um
oh i forget i forget her name right now
the author she used to be a trader um
algorithmic trading she's now
kind of a big like data scientist for
good type of figure
and
yeah that's it thank you trevor cathy
o'neil
um and so i'm just curious if in your
trading days you came across this
situation where um i've heard that at
least for some of the hedge funds
if you're an algorithmic trader you
can't even talk to the person who sits
right next to you it's very much
discouraged like people even fear
reaching out to each other outside of
work for help on technical concepts the
idea being that
if you fail or quit like you you know
leave the firm with just your intel and
not sort of the
the greater scheme of how the portfolio
is kind of you know managing the
portfolio i'm just curious if that's
something you've come across
honestly no thankfully um i think
because i didn't work for like a hedge
fund i worked for a company who traded
for clients
um it wasn't
i was never in that kind of cutthroat
trading desk um environment thankfully
um but i can definitely see how that
could happen um especially because
within the trading world it seems like
um
people that i've known you know so i've
been in the business for 17 years
um and there are so many people that i
know that have been at three different
firms you know they flip flop and they
they're always moving around um so
that that tendency to hold on to your
proprietary knowledge i'm sure is
um is very prevalent but no i did not um
i didn't i didn't experience any of that
in in my positions because of kind of
the nature of what our trading dust did
thank you thanks
thanks aaron i see someone else asked an
anonymous question that was domain
knowledge and trading and finance seems
like an absolute prerequisite
how do you build that knowledge from the
outside
for example someone who's never worked
in finance
um
well i mean
i guess just reading about it um
i mean i i always
i always wanted i was always interested
in that um like i said my undergrad was
in psychology um but then i worked at a
bank in college and i kind of got into
just finance in general and i realized i
really liked money and i really liked
working with money
um and so then i
um
i thought oh i would love to like trade
that would be cool
um
and i started looking into it and um i
just i found a job at td ameritrade for
a starting broker so i just i applied
and i learned um but i didn't have any
knowledge coming into that
um
but i think if you if you don't
get an actual job doing that i mean
there are so many resource resources out
there now um that weren't there when i
started
um you know even
like schwab and td ameritrade have
classes and classes and classes that you
can take for free um to learn how to
trade so um really you just have to be
proactive and find find sources out
there because there are plenty of
resources to to teach you how the stock
market works um different ways to trade
um
what what there is to trade and how to
trade it um so yeah i mean it's it's out
there you just have to kind of be
diligent and go find it
i absolutely love your approach that
when you say oh i think i would be
interested in this and that sounds fun
and you just go do it because i think so
many of us think that and we
we don't necessarily just go do it
yeah actually when um my uh when i got
my data analyst job that was one thing
my hearing manager he mentioned to me
once he's like you know people talk
about it but i could see you're you're
actually doing it you're actually taking
the classes on your own so that showed
me that you
were going to do it and and that you you
were putting forth the effort and he
said that was like really big for him to
see
that's great
ali i see um you had asked the question
in the chat
too around networking do you want to ask
that one live
yeah aaron i think you kind of answered
it for me and you've definitely talked
about it um over the course of this
discussion but just if you were going to
kind of
try to make a number out of the ratio of
networking within your organization
versus like professional development
with outside what would you say
the balance was like there
for me personally or what you should do
well
both
um
i mean i probably
i mean it's probably 50 50 but maybe a
little bit more internally
um for me um
i did uh
once i moved to chicago i was more
um outside um
i i participated in more um kind of
industry things uh like women in etfs
and and um
security traders association things like
that um and that's where i made a lot of
contacts that way because i was in a
bigger city
um but before that was probably more
internal um so i think it's i kind of
had a good mix
um throughout my career of both which i
think is important to do both because
um
obviously within your organization if
you're gonna stay there forever
then people inside there are gonna help
you but if you uh
if the time comes where you have to
leave
and um you know do a career change or
just shift companies then those out
external resources are really going to
come in handy and
and uh
and help you with contacts outside the
firm so i think both are really
important
thank you
thanks erin trevor i see you have your
hand raised you want to jump in
yes hello hi everyone
um some question for you erin they you
know we have been reading for
years now
um
data and automation
is actually affecting the finance
industry
not only in terms of accounting but also
in terms of trading right so
people like us are building are building
algorithms that are being deployed at
scale
right so we we really where
people have to re-skill up skill or
change industries
because of that um to what extent have
you seen that where you are and and does
that
you think affect
i mean people should consider that if
they are trying to enter the field of
finance is that something that's
important
yeah i think definitely it is
yeah i um i did i i haven't seen that
last two years because of of what i've
been doing but when i was still trading
um
that was
one catalyst that that made me start to
get interested in in the algo side
because
um when i first started on block trading
i did a lot of manual trading where you
we call it high touch trading where you
just you're just firing off a lot of
little orders all throughout the day and
you're you're monitoring things
constantly um just manually
um that was a big part of my job and
then as as the years went on we started
using algorithms a lot more to kind of
um supplement that and kind of shifted
it to where like it's kind of taken away
my job a little bit
um
not not exactly but you know shifting um
so yeah i mean i think that's it's just
going to keep going that way um but you
also still need manual interference to
make sure that things run right and
that's kind of where people like us come
in to make sure that those etls are
running and everything is working
smoothly
but yeah there's definitely been a shift
over i don't know maybe the last 10
years or so that um i did i did start to
see it when i was on the trade desk for
sure
so that's something to be aware of
all right thank you
aaron there was a question earlier as
well that was
what are your favorite professional
resources podcasts websites or
newsletters
um
i mean i've i look at everything um i
mean i took
i took courses through udacity udemy
linkedin learning um
um
you know
codeacademy
everything i've i've taken everything um
so i mean i don't know that i really
have favorites i just kind of
um
will search for something like oh i want
to i want to uh you know brush up on
doing this so i wouldn't learn how to do
this so i just look for a class and
and uh
and find one that kind of fits what i'm
you know looking for
um
yeah i can't
i don't really have like a go-to that i
always you know go to for sources um
yeah i kind of just look to see what's
out there and see what speaks to me
how do you keep yourself motivated when
you decide like i'm going to learn this
it's difficult
um
i think the biggest thing you can do is
just um
kind of schedule yourself a little bit
and take a break when you need to um
so
like this week for example
i was gonna take a new class because i
don't really have much on my calendar
this week i don't have a lot of meetings
there's a lot of people out for spring
break and stuff you know people take off
when their kids are out of school and so
i don't really have a lot of meetings so
i was like well i'm going to take some
you know some classes um so just start
scheduling things and you know if i'm if
i'm i'm like
reading through something or taking a
class and i'm just getting burnt out
just
take a break
walk away go walk my dog
do something you know just uh just to
step away from it um i think that what i
used to fall in i used to fall into the
trap of like okay i gotta take this
class this is a four hour class i can
knock this out in a day because it's
four hours but you don't
realize the mental
um stamina you have to have to really
sit through that class and actually
learn it um so that's i mean i think
that's the biggest thing is just taking
breaks and
and um doing going at your own pace to
make sure that it's actually
helpful to you don't just you know get
through something just to get through it
because you're not really getting
anything out of it at that point
that's a great point
i'm just scrolling through to make sure
i haven't missed questions so feel free
to raise your hand too if you want to
jump in and ask them live i think that
you had one earlier mike if you want to
jump in
around domain background
yeah and it's kind of a
a balancing act i was thinking of about
i mean clearly you've come into this
role with a lot of domain knowledge
right and
and so if you were sitting with someone
who's producing a model or producing
some predictions and stuff
you know
you must apply
or
i'm assuming you apply some domain
knowledge to what you're hearing and and
then kind of balance up well does that
sound right does that not sound right
um
and i'm interested in
you know
it it seems to me a great fit to bring
domain knowledge and then put modeling
and data
techniques and and you know experience
on top
the other way though is harder right
because then you know someone could sit
and and torture the data for hours and
hours and days and days
and you could come in with your domain
knowledge and go well why are you doing
it like this
so you know it
how how do you balance up domain
knowledge and it's like well i wouldn't
even build a model of this you know
because there's other things that you
could do versus
the kind of data centric side
i think that's that's why it's really
important to have a well-rounded team
or
colleagues that you can go to that have
that you know that complement you um
we had uh
i can't remember the details but i
remember
when when i was a data analyst um there
was something that we were working on
um me and a colleague who was not that
business savvy he was newer to the
company
um
and
i remember we were going over something
and we we pulled you know we we queried
some some data and i was like well
that's not right and he's like why isn't
it right i'm like because that's not
right that's not it was it was like um
i think it was like trading volume
related or something um it was something
that i knew that that didn't look right
you know um but he didn't know it didn't
look right and so we had to you know we
had to kind of um pull our talents to
try to figure out like why isn't that
right and how to get it right um so yeah
i mean i think
nobody knows everything you know i'm um
i'm uh i'm certainly more
business knowledge than than technical
knowledge but i'm still working on my
technical knowledge and there's people
that are the opposite but yeah you just
you have to find those people that
compliment you to try to work together
to to get that um you know ultimate goal
reached
um but yeah i can see it's
i can see how it would be much harder
coming
knowing um being very highly technical
but not knowing
what you're talking about um in real
life um that was actually
that was another thing that kind of
um
initially made me want to get into kind
of the tech world um because i would
talk to these tech guys and they just
they didn't
seem human they didn't know how to speak
to me
um
and i thought well i'm smart i could
probably learn this stuff
maybe i could like translate between the
two groups of people
you know um i think we need more of that
in um in all industries because i think
they are very segregated um those two
kind of worlds and i think the more
people that we have that can can speak
to both sides i think
that's where um that's where we need to
be going
i wonder whether it
having that background in the domain
leads you to
kind of
not go down to the
more complex model rabbit holes
and rather you're kind of looking for
simpler more explainable models let's
say like that
yeah that could be i mean
um
yeah you're gonna you're gonna um
you know shift to where you're
comfortable
so yeah which again i think is another
reason why you need um people that
compliment you that can push you um
outside of your comfort zone to get the
best result
yeah
no it's it's
it's good to hear that i i think it
matches my
feeling that you need both
in a data team
to kind of counterbalance each other
yeah i think it's definitely helpful no
matter no matter what you're working on
no matter what industry in i think it's
it's beneficial for
for whatever you're doing
i really like that idea or the point
about needing more people that can be
the translator in between
the very technical and in business side
yeah
yeah
but are there a lot of companies hiring
for roles like that or what what are
those roles i don't know you know that's
that's just kind of what i think there
should be i don't know if it is out
there i don't know if that exists
but i think it should
um and that's kind of
what i would like to do um or you know
eventually be you know to be
to be the um
to be the expert on both sides you know
like
oh yeah she can talk technical go talk
to her or yeah she can explain like you
know the logistical side and you know
the business side you know
um
yeah i mean i don't know if there's an
actual position
that um
that is called like a you know technical
liaison or something like that i don't
know but
i think it definitely should exist
that's one of the reasons i've called
myself professional geek
you know because i i find myself in that
translator role or in that kind of your
role and it's tough because i've never
fit a machine learning model in my life
you know and yet i'm kind of sitting
alongside data scientists
but you can you can understand them and
you can speak to them which is
very sometimes
sometimes
i see melody you said product managers
are generous generally this translator
type position
yeah
can't be
i see eric you're
you commented in that you can relate to
your to this as well do you want to
weigh in
yeah it's always been one of those
things where it's never in a typical
like statistician or data sciences job
description where i work but because
like mike said i'm definitely a fellow
geek of many things in tech and made a
lot of great relationships with our
research i.t group so i'm often helping
people connect dots or translate
concepts from
the stat side to the i.t devops side and
vice versa but i personally think that
should be recognized more but that's a
much broader discussion that we don't
have time for here
i love tatsu's analogy well i love all
restaurant analogies
tatsu you said i would translate between
the front of the house and the back of
the house
is
yeah i think i i love this conversation
because i think that it happens
everywhere right it's not just
you know this industry it's it's across
the board um
and yeah
it's it's funny because people can't
talk to other people um and yeah with my
analogy like i
i worked as um a sushi chef on the line
and you would not believe you know how
heated things would get when your server
needs to get this order out immediately
but you've got a stacked line of orders
and these chefs are you know working
their tails off they don't want to hear
that but you have to go about it in a
way that you can actually serve the
customers
right like that's the end goal
um and yeah it takes a little bit
finesse i i definitely think it takes
somebody that can
you know understand
you know the big picture and like take
input and actually you know um make it
into
to something actionable right and and
actually produce a result that is going
to be you know the best outcome for
everybody so yeah i love this
conversation
and i've just thought of the the job
title for these people these translator
people
if they're internal to your company they
don't have a name if they're external to
the company they're called consultants
and they make five x year salary
yeah
good point
i mean internally
or do we just call them empaths like is
that what it is
aaron said the bob's from office space
yes
israel i see you have your hand raised
too if you want to jump in um yeah no i
agree with uh tetsu was saying about
like um
you know using finish of a speech like
explaining how like a model could relate
to a restaurant i think like a key part
at least for my success about getting
buy-in from executives or different
parts of the business on different
analytics solutions from machine
learning to just automating a report
that used to be an excel report uh comes
to like sharing a story
um i at least personally i see a lot of
non-technical individuals once they
understand like the metaphor or you know
something similar they can relate to
like i work in finance so like uh we're
trying to talk about like attrition
models for customers and it's if i
instead of going to explain the math of
them i'm like if we try to identify a
new like 20 bill that is fake but we
have all these tailors you know test
different results probably different
input and we gathered that you know as a
voting i was just trying to explain the
model but like if we can use stories i
think a lot of the non-taken individuals
really have that translation and once
that they have that clicked in it's a
lot easier to continue
uh building more technical knowledge to
them
but i love the restaurant analogy that's
great
great points
and thank you all so much and aaron i
i was just wondering what's the best way
for people to get in touch with you if
they have follow-up questions or want to
connect
uh linkedin's great
okay cool
thank you so much aaron for sharing all
your insights with us and experience
this is great
you